In this lesson we have introduced
the P versus NP problem.
As we said in the beginning, the class
P informally captures the problems
we can solve efficiently on a computer,
and the class NP
captures the problems whose answers we
can verify efficiently on a computer.
Our experience with finding a clique in
a graph is just that these two classes
are not the same.
Cliques are hard to find,
but they are easy to check.
Intuitively solving a difficult
problem should be harder
than just checking a solution.
Nevertheless, no one has been able
to prove that P is not equal to NP.
Whether these two classes are equivalent
is known as the P versus NP question and
is the most important problem in
theoretical computer science today.
If not in all of mathematics.
We'll discuss the full implications
of the question in a later lecture.
But for now,
I'll just mention that in the year 2000,
the Clay Mathematics Institute
named the P versus NP problem
as one of the seven most important
open questions in mathematics.
And has offered a $1 million bounty for
a proof that determines whether or
not P equals NP.
Fame and fortune await the person that
settles the P versus NP problem, but
many have tried and failed.
Next class we look at
the NP complete problems.
The hardest problems in NP.